an author of the new book Reaper ghost
target a sniper novel former Brigadier
General Tony Tata also with us retired
CIA senior intelligence officer sana ram
policy group vice president Daniel
Hoffman mr. Hoffman let's start with you
I think we're obviously a little closer
it looks like it's happening you know
Russia better than anybody they pulled
their ships out earlier today obviously
they're expecting something they are and
I can tell you from the perspective of a
CIA officer who served I've served in
Moscow for five years and in the Middle
East our intelligence community is on a
full-court press you know collecting
intelligence on Russia's actions right
now military and diplomatic and then
what they might do in response to our
military action yeah all right general
Teta at this point with all the bluster
from Moscow now Putin himself when you
when when Russia starts pulling their
ships out they obviously don't want to
be collateral damage here or involved in
this so would you say that the threats
that they're making Moscow's making
though they'll take our missiles out of
the sky is that an empty threat I don't
think it's an empty threat Sean I think
what they may be doing is trying to save
face with the Syria as they remove all
possible threat from you know US
airplanes that jets missiles that could
be coming in and and I just like to say
unlike what the Democrats have been
trying to do in this country for the
last 16 months which is to remove a duly
elected president regime changes are not
our goal in Syria in fact what we should
be doing is in what we are doing is
applying the elements of national power
diplomatic information military economic
in aid to enable our national security
strategy which is to essentially prevent
weapons of mass destruction and to have
an international order based on the rule
a real quick last exit questioner you
both convinced that this was a sod in
Syria no chance otherwise
oh you've danced at the same time 100%
yes
all right thank you both